[Music]
here's a dumb one to start the bonus
that's definitely after the main episode
so i got dog [ __ ] sleep
and i had a very vivid dream that i was
pissing in a urinal
and
i
i have a big rule don't pee in my dreams
what oh i thought you're gonna say
sit down to pee oh yeah i got a big roll
man i never pee in a urinal ever so it
was a nightmare because i was standing
what about the rule yeah
no
no i was thinking about that scene and
inception where leo's like telling the
guy you remember like we did the
trainings so if anyone tries to hack
your mind i'm here to stop them from
doing that okay do you remember that i
don't it's been a while since i've seen
that movie whatever i was just thinking
about that scene but it's just me
pissing in a dream and leo shows up and
he's like wait remember you're training
i'm here to prevent you from peeing your
pants on the outside [ __ ] off man that's
weird remember your training turn around
sit down
[Laughter]
but i have to pee dude don't pee you're
gonna pee on the outside what do you
mean on the outside i'm awake right now
he's gonna piss himself the whole
inception team just wired in with those
leads and then me on the oh i see where
you're going yeah the adjacent bed yeah
and my pants just start soiling
and they all get up and rip the leads
off they're like we [ __ ] failed damn
it
[Laughter]
that's funny thanks sweet
that's funny yeah and then like you have
you need the recursion though right yeah
what's the next leg i don't know like
maybe you like fall into the urinal by
accident and then you're like a layer
deeper okay and you're like underwater
in a pool and you're like about to piss
and leo's like no don't pee you're so
warm in the pool yeah
dude you're like you know how in the
third layer he was like deep inside that
[ __ ]
fortress so it was like you know heavily
guarded yeah instead of a pool i'm just
in the middle of like the ocean in
mexico so it's really warm yeah i'm just
floating out there in negative space
naked yeah
and the whole leo and his boys have to
like dive in and underwater convince me
not to pee
just sitting there shaking my little
wiener on water
what why not
why wouldn't i if there's an ocean
[Music]
they can't even kick me back under there
to wake me up i'm just shaking my little
toddler wiener underneath the water
he's soiling oh god he's soiling two
layers deep with soil i'm peeing in the
water and then in the second layer
no in real life you pee a little bit and
then it stops yeah
just leo's looking they're tugging me by
the wiener
swimming with you bringing you back to
shore
just like a starfish like like a dog
boat yeah